a local family is mourning the loss of
their six-month-old baby after police
say a woman on parole crashed into their
car thanks for joining us here at five
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus
Saturday night police say 36-year-old
Tiffany Carter left the scene of a crash
at Nellis and Sahara she then reportedly
caused a second crash at Nellis in Vegas
Valley Drive Joshua paguero Joins us
live from Sunrise Hospital where the
victims are being treated Joshua
Brian Denise the father of the child
Wilbur Castro is under a coma his family
says and the 31 year old according to
family members and Friends suffered
traumatic brain injuries his mother the
child's grandmother is also hospitalized
as well and they're all praying for a
speedy recovery but also for justice
Friends of the family identify the six
month old as ethian Castro they say the
family was heading home when the driver
struck their car Metro says Carter was
driving a pickup Southbound on Nellis
when she reportedly ran a red light
causing the crash she was placed under
arrest and faces numerous charges
including four counts of DUI resulting
in substantial bodily harm
records also show the registration on
Carter's pickup was suspended we've
learned she has a lengthy criminal
history dating back to 2005 with
convictions for kidnapping burglary
attempting robbery and conspiracy to
commit robbery as for the family they
are from Venezuela arriving to the
United States eight months ago in a
GoFundMe post the child's mother says
quote we did not believe that our plans
and dreams would change overnight due to
the Reckless actions of another person
the family is also looking to raise 25
thousand dollars to cover medical
expenses reporting live from Sunrise
Hospital Joshua progero 8 News Now